I've been misgendered all day every
single interaction conversation
everything
just Mr from the beginning day to now
I'm just sick of it I'm sick of
correcting people who won't listen I'm
and those sick of people not seeing me
I'm sick of it I'm so sick of it and
then I'm like oh well if I went on tape
this would never happen but what
I just left to believe that trans people
exist
and to look at me and think for a split
second like oh maybe they don't want to
be called a lady maybe maybe that's
uh uh this one is some of the videos are
funny
some of the videos with these really
over the top flamboyant people making a
big spectacle of themselves saying why
it's ma'am what do you mean I'm a six
foot four dude but you didn't call me
ma'am actually it's men and that's kind
of funny this one's not funny to me